uber CEO Travis kalanick will take an
indefinite leave of absence as the
ride-hailing service tries to change its
troubled culture he wrote in an email to
employees yesterday that it's to work on
myself and to focus on building out a
world-class leadership team uber
released a report yesterday by former
attorney General Eric Holder with his 47
recommendations for the company now they
include transferring some of Callanetics
responsibilities creating new
requirements to handle harrassment
complaints and committing to improve
diversity holders investigation was
prompted by a scathing blog post by
former Erb employee that Susan Fowler
who alleged sexual harassment and
mismanagement CBS News contributors Jodi
Kanter Nicholas Thompson are here at the
table Jodi is a New York Times
correspondent and Nick is
editor-in-chief of Wired magazine good
morning to you both good morning Gail so
let's set the tone
Jodi if you will for that board meeting
because mr. bannerman is saying that his
comments were taken out of context the
talking he was trying to say is really a
good thing that's certainly not how it
was interpreted well this was about the
most extraordinary employee meeting you
can imagine as my colleague Mike Isaak
reported the former attorney general has
just investigated the company they're
saying that they're going to remake this
company from top to bottom there's a lot
of leadership vacancy at the top the CEO
is about to take a leave of absence the
whistleblower who revealed the sexual
harassment at the company is getting a
round of applause at this meeting and
then a board member takes this remark
which is widely construed a success
which seems to kind of reenact the
entire problem in the first place well
in fact Arianna Huffington announces
that they're going to add a second board
member and she says there's a lot of
data that shows when there's one woman
on the board it's much more likely that
there will be a second woman on the
board and then Bonderman says well it
actually shows there's going to be more
talking this is as they're promoting
that they're going to change the culture
the patient's day talking is a good
thing was he not well we can't know here
what exactly the statement saying he has
released a statement saying that I think
anybody who made that comment would have
released a statement saying their
comment had been misinterpreted yes yes
but I think the greater point here is
that it leads to questions about whether
this company can really change
yeah well they're certainly taking the
steps to do that are they not naked
therapist : ik is going to take a leave
of absence we don't know for how long
yet yeah this is a massively broken
company at the moment and there are huge
business implications to it they have
unanimously accepted the many many many
recommendations from the holder report
which basically will turn it into a
completely different company right they
have been operating like a pirate ship
for many years they are now who to turn
into something more like a cruise line
okay but have all gained such a market
advantage and market share that they can
change now taking advantage of what
happened before and create an even
better company this is so interesting
we're going to look back ten years from
now because there is one theory that
they have had a culture they have had a
style it has worked up to this point
maybe changing the culture won't work or
maybe this is exactly the right moment
and this will actually be a great thing
for ubers business they will be a more
responsible company they will make more
responsible decisions it will be easier
for them to recruit and retain people
have already achieved the market share
and they've got the market share in the
near monopoly or not monopoly position
but a very strong market position well
think about three groups of people think
about customers if you're a woman
hailing an uber alone late at night do
you want to associate that brand with
rampant sexual harassment and
misbehavior think about potential
employees if you want to come to work at
this company you're going to read that
holder report and what conclusions are
you going to draw about this as a
potential workplace and then think about
investors this company has a seventy
billion dollar valuation it is a huge
amount of money that now hangs in the
balance what about some of the other
changes that uber plans to make I mean
some are cosmetic I mean changing the
war room to the peace room which seems I
call it cosmetic for a reason clearly
but what about some of the other changes
that they're going to make so they're
gonna make I mean the war room of the
peace room I feel like they should have
called it the strategy room but the
peace room was a little bit of like
overkill there so a lot of the changes
will do with the way they rank employees
the way they measure employees the
processes they have for people to
elevate complaints the way they will
recruit for diversity it really is a
long long report about best practices
for building a diverse and inclusive
workforce it actually is a really good
document for any leader of an
organization to read about the steps you
need to take to
build a good workplace fascinating
though that the whistleblower gets
applause when do you see that happening
it all started with Susan Fowler's blog
it's very rare I mean something is
happening right now if you look at this
in conjunction with what happened at Fox
we now see two major CEOs kind of
signature CEOs whose work had so much
cultural value who set the tone of major
companies who now have either had to
resign or take leave of absences because
of sexual harassment and want to say one
more thing about uber they have this big
problem this big cultural problem they
also have a bunch of other lawsuits
hanging over them particularly the fight
with Google over the self-driving car
technology which is absolutely key to
their future so they can solve all their
internal culture problems and they've
still got a lot to go through
Thompson Jody cancer great to have both
of you great to be here